[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia áfrica y francia se vuelven a
encontrar esta vez para la cumbre en
montpellier de octubre de 2021 que tiene
por lema reinventando juntos la relación
una relación de cuantiosos episodios
tortuosos que en los últimos años
francia ha querido reconocer desde que
el presidente emmanuel macrón dio su
discurso en uagadugú capital de burkina
faso en noviembre de 2017 pertenezco a
una generación de franceses para quienes
los crímenes de la colonización europea
son innegables y forman parte de nuestra
historia 12 países africanos hacen parte
de esta nueva cumbre áfrica francia de
los cuales la mayoría guardan una
historia trágica por la dominación y el
yugo francés la huella de francia sobre
áfrica comenzó desde 1830 con el proceso
de colonización en argelia unas décadas
después en el congo túnez y la isla de
madagascar eran tiempos en que las
potencias europeas penetraban el
continente africano y se lo repartían
como un pastel para comienzos del siglo
la dominación de francia se había
extendido con tal éxito que en 1904 se
creó oficialmente la áfrica occidental
francesa que incluyó a 8 países una
campaña que se extendió a la áfrica
ecuatorial francesa con nuevos
territorios colonizados como gabón congo
chad y la actual república
centroafricana a juzgar por estas
imágenes de
1958 durante la gira del general charles
de gaulle a lo largo de las posesiones
francesas en áfrica occidental es
evidente que su presencia era altamente
celebrada por la población local pero no
se debía malinterpretar la gran estima
de la que gozaba el general en áfrica
con que los africanos quisieran seguir
bajo el manto francés había peticiones
de independencia en varios de los países
africanos y para 1960 la consiguieron 17
de éstos en una suerte de efecto dominó
pero no todos los países lograron una
independencia por la vía diplomática de
hecho uno de los casos más lamentables
fue el de argelia la colonia que francia
quiso retener a toda costa argelia
sufrió un proceso de liberación que le
costó una guerra de largos ocho años
desde 1954 hasta 1962 el frente de
liberación nacional de argelia fungió
como una guerrilla que se enfrentó a
sangre y fuego al ejército francés ya
los denominados harkis francia venía de
perder indochina su gran colonia en asia
y no se permitiría perder su más antigua
y próxima colonia en áfrica de manera
que lanzó una violenta represión a las
hostilidades efectuadas por el frente de
liberación nacional finalmente en 1962
con un saldo de 1.5 millones de
argelinos muertos y tras un abrumador
referendo independentista se firmaron
los acuerdos de viana en los cuales
francia le otorgó a argelia su derecho
soberano de autogobernarse
pese a la descolonización y el
sentimiento de una áfrica libre
continuaron los episodios tortuosos que
involucraron a francia en este
continente uno de los casos más sonados
actualmente en la responsabilidad de
francia en el genocidio de ruanda en
1994 y durante 100 días el gobierno
ejecutó un intento de exterminio de la
población tutsi en la cual murieron
alrededor de 800 mil de ellos en 2017 el
gobierno de ruanda encargó al bufete de
abogados lady fire stan smith con sede
en washington un informe donde se
concluyó que el gobierno francés pudo
prever que se avecinaba un genocidio
además se consigna en el informe que los
funcionarios franceses armaron
asesoraron capacitar on equiparon y
protegieron al gobierno de ruanda sin
prestar atención a la destrucción y la
muerte de los tutsis en mayo de 2021 el
presidente macrón visitó ruanda y
reconoció la responsabilidad francesa en
el genocidio
dónde no
a dimitir
al estar hoy junto a ustedes con
humildad y respeto reconozco nuestras
responsabilidades yo he ángel bonet no
responsability
si tens y possible
se trata pues de continuar la labor de
conocimiento y verdad que sólo permite
el trabajo riguroso de los
investigadores e historiadores y
seguiremos haciéndolo en un próximo con
el fin que este ha llegado un escenario
en el que podemos ver una relación mejor
quizás más profunda entre ruanda y
franjas de
france
otro de los países africanos donde en
los últimos años se ha cuestionado la
legitimidad de la intervención francesa
en sus asuntos internos es malí con el
objetivo de sofocar la expansión de los
grupos terroristas como al qaeda en el
magreb el por entonces presidente
françois hollande ordenó la operación
serbal el 11 de enero de 2013 esta
operación fue continuada por la
operación barkan lanzada el primero de
agosto de 2014 en la cual francia
desplegó 4.500 soldados en la región del
sahel la penetración militar francesa
despertó la indignación del pueblo
maliense con arengas de abajo francia o
francia lárgate manifestantes malienses
reclamaron la salida de las tropas
francesas de su territorio con sendas
protestas a finales de 2019 y comienzos
de 2020 60 años después de haberse
independizado de francia malí aún estaba
bajo intervención militar francesa pese
a la promesa de macrón de un recorte
progresivo de sus tropas en el sahel
como malí ruanda
y son varios los países africanos que
han sufrido profundas heridas por el rol
de francia como potencia imperial una
relación tortuosa que actualmente busca
reinventarse así terminamos soy andrés
suárez jaramillo gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
puntos
i